throwing indestructible lizards into
Vats of acid hunting strange chicken men
through forests in Ireland arguing in
Latin with a man wearing a haunted Roman
centurion's helmet when you join the SCP
Foundation you might be expecting high
octane drama of the time especially with
the name street sweepers you'd expect
this mobile task force to be neck deep
in some real action-packed street racing
maybe you wouldn't think that they'd be
tasked with driving all day every day in
four hour shifts tailing a semi truck
all over Birmingham Alabama but as agent
Moore and his colleague pulled into the
lay-by behind the truck neither of them
were ready for what they were about to
witness
scp-2590 was first discovered by the
foundation at a routine traffic stop
investigating a totally different
anomaly in the Birmingham area agents
Peters and Smith had been posing as
local police officers the foundation had
been trying to track down an artifact
that was supposedly being smuggled
across the U.S in the back of a
nondescript station wagon Peterson Smith
had been allocated a pair of beat-up old
police cruisers which they'd parked
across the dirt road fully blocking any
traffic from coming through it was
several hours into their shift when the
incident occurred just at the point they
were starting to lose focus taking a
look through the suitcases in
memorabilia from a family's trip to
Disney World Peters had taken way too
long to hear the noise of the engine
swelling behind him he spun around to
see the hulking shape of the semi-truck
barreling straight towards him agent
Smith and a family of five with only two
seconds to react he yelled out at the
top of his lungs and dived out of the
way leaving the trunk of the car wide
open with five screams emerging from
inside Smith who had been sitting in one
of the Cruisers only just managed to get
out before the semi made contact eyes
closed agent Peters waited for the
inevitable sound of screaming rubber the
bang of metal on metal shower of Glass
on asphalt but it never came when he
opened his eyes the station wagon was
still parked up in front of them the two
police crews are still blocking the road
and all the Disney merch still piled
high in the trunk the semi was driving
off along the road on the other side of
their blockade with not a scratch on it
without a moment's hesitation agent
Smith who had kept his eyes open and
witnessed the whole thing leapt into
action he ordered his partner still
lying confused in the dirt to administer
Class A and nestics to the family and
call in for backup agent Smith himself
jammed his keys into the ignition
twisting them so hard he almost bent the
metal and took off after the vehicle
what agent Smith and Peters had just
witnessed was the very first Foundation
exposure to
scp-2590 fondly nicknamed trailer trash
as Smith pulled up alongside the vehicle
and studied it for the first time he
made a note of its initial appearance
over the radio an appearance which
remains changed years later the badges
on the vehicle claim that it is an
International ProStar day cab
semi-trailer truck complete with an
unmarked trailer as the agent flicked on
his lights and indicated that the
vehicle should pull over he noted that
it didn't have any license plates on it
either front or rear he leaned forward
in his seat trying to peer into the cab
to make out the driver but in the
Alabama Sun the man just looked like a
shadowy figure they drove side by side
along the road for almost a mile the
truck made no signs of pulling over
despite agent Smith's continued
insistence and repeated flashes of the
cop lights but it also didn't attempt to
pull away either it just continued to
drive a few miles per hour below the
speed limit the driver didn't seem to
look across at him once having discussed
it with Foundation staff they decided it
was best not to draw attention to the
situation they had no idea whether this
SCP was hostile or posed any threat to
civilian life but having blue and red
lights flashing at it appeared to be
doing little to change the situation
instead he switched off the sirens and
pulled in behind the truck tailing it
around Birmingham as the foundation
readied for their agents to respond to
the situation for almost an hour nothing
of note happened agent Smith drove
behind the trailer watching it like a
hawk he observed that it obeyed every
traffic law to a t it never broke the
speed limit never cut anyone off and
left room for other vehicles to merge if
it hadn't seen it drive straight through
a roadblock as if it wasn't there he
would have never suspected a thing but
then the truck turned its turn signal on
they had just come off the highway and
merged onto a quiet side street just as
the sun was starting to hang low in the
sky the truck crept across the side of
the road squeezing its brakes gently and
stopped agent Smith matched the action
the whole way pulling up about 20 feet
behind the trailer in constant radio
communication he kicked open his door
and stepped out into to the evening air
Foundation Personnel advised that he
keep his hand on his gun at all times
and approach with caution he didn't
really need them to tell him that Smith
called for the driver to step out of the
cab no response the truck just sat there
with its hazards on engine off after a
moment there was a clunk and the trailer
door started to slowly open all by
itself agent Smith called in backup but
there were still several minutes out
instead he ran back to the car gun
raised and waited to see what was inside
as the doors slowly opened to reveal
nothing no not quite nothing there was
something small on the floor of the
trailer right in the center as if it
hadn't been moved around at all by the
vehicle's motion it was red a kind of
elongated cuboid he reported it all to
the foundation over his radio then
paused when he recognized what it was a
KitKat candy bar or to be more specific
a Kit Kat chunky what happened after
this point was hazy agent Smith was
found on the roadside just 20 minutes
later confused about what had happened
the truck was nowhere in sight however a
security camera from a convenience store
just up the street happened to capture
the interaction in the footage you see
agent Smith approaching the trailer with
his gun raised looking at the KitKat he
tries to enter the trailer but is unable
to so he approaches the driver's side
door while talking to the shadowy figure
in the cab he drops his gun and stands
motionless a confused and sleepy
expression on his face until the trailer
door closes and the SCP drives away
contact was re-established with
scp-2590 soon after and has been
maintained almost uninterrupted ever
since the findings made on that initial
encounter seem to hold true across
further examination Personnel have
reached out to Navistar International
the company that supposedly manufactures
this model of semi-truck but there
appears to be no records of its creation
or shipment to the US in fact no
documentary education at all can be
attributed to the truck or any
components on it the driver in the front
cab is a humanoid figure who is
perpetually shrouded in Shadow
designated
scp-2590-1 attempts to reveal the
driver's figures have proved ineffective
as even powerful spotlights do not shed
enough light into the cab to render the
driver visible quite what this driver's
role is in the operation of scp-2590 is
unknown
scp-2590-1 appears to have some
proximity-based amnestic qualities as
anyone approaching it on foot has
reported memory loss and confusion soon
after just like agent Smith as also
discovered by the two agents and their
roadblock containment of this SCP is
simply not possible while the majority
of the time the SCP is corporeal it
possesses the ability to pass through
solid objects at will all attempted
roadblocks have resulted in the same
thing happening the SCP will just phase
right through on them as if nothing was
there since it cannot be contained in
the usual way a different operation has
been set up to monitor the truck's
activities which so far have proven to
be apparently harmless to the civilian
population mobile task force gamma 133
also known as the street sweepers has
been established to follow this SCP
around Birmingham at all times they
operate in four hour shifts with two
agents in unmarked Vehicles sticking
close behind the trailer at all times
the foundation was able to fit a
tracking device onto it as well
providing researchers with continuous
location data for where they can find
the vehicle at seemingly random times
supposedly determined by the SCP itself
it pulls over somewhere quiet and opens
the door to its trailer the door will
remain open for 60 seconds and then
close again any attempts to enter the
trailer have been blocked by some kind
of invisible barrier seemingly
impenetrable to most approaches more
violent and destructive methods of Entry
cannot be authorized for testing due to
the heavy civilian population in the
surrounding area every time the doors
open there is something different in the
trailer researchers are trying to
ascertain some kind of pattern or
messaging behind most of the objects but
many seem to be random the current list
of things that have appeared in the back
of scp-2590 include an iPhone 3G a red
apple and a lit light bulb without any
visible form of power supply most
notable about the objects in the trailer
is that often they appear to be human
beings as happened on the knife that
agent Moore was on duty in the street
sweepers the agents pulled in behind the
truck as per usual when it slowed to a
stop beside the highway agent Moore got
out of the vehicle second unenthused
about the monotony of the task he had
been assigned expecting to see a
cardboard box or a ChapStick when the
trailer door opened he was left shocked
when he came face to face with himself
few people can say they have seen
themselves in real life most of them
have been administered with various
amnestics to make them forget but agent
Moore went on to report how bizarre of
an experience it was he claimed that it
was utterly unlike looking in a mirror
where your reflection is flipped and
follows your every move seeing yourself
standing in three dimensions moving
independently and evidently in a great
deal of distress is an experience that
few would envy anytime a human being
materializes in the trailer they appear
to be in a great deal of distress as
they attempt to escape through the
invisible barrier agent Moore and his
partner agent Hall could do nothing but
stand and watch in confusion as the copy
of him attempted to free himself before
after the usual 60 seconds the trailer
door closed and the vehicle pulled away
again several instances have occurred of
duplicate humans appearing in the
trailer but each time the original
person seems to have had no knowledge of
this taking place and nothing out of the
ordinary happens to them however there
appears to be some small pattern
demonstrating the SCP as an awareness of
the foundation as it has also duplicated
agent inglis's sister who has no
connection to this SCP at all incident
16 was the most distressing of all as a
large slab of metal appeared in the back
of the trailer with the SCP Foundation
logo painted across it agent Inglis and
Schultz were on duty at this time and
observed copious amounts of blood
flowing out of the metal slab before
long the blood filled the back of the
trailer pushing up against the invisible
barrier all of a sudden 52 seconds into
the encounter the barrier vanished and a
Cascade of blood with the slab inside
were launched out of the two agents at a
speed of over 190 kilometers an hour
killing them both instantly since this
incident
scp-2590 has been treated with greater
caution the most mysterious thing to
have come from researching this truck
came on December 4th 2011 when for the
first time the truck trucks tracking
Beacon stopped working it had been seen
pulling into an abandoned warehouse and
so a team of street sweepers was
immediately dispatched to investigate
when they arrived they found the vehicle
moving through the warehouse at a slow
crawl choosing to pursue on foot and
leave a pair of agents at the entrance
they followed the SCP through the
facility until it came to what agents
described as a service tunnel or sewer
of some sort putting headlamps on they
followed the truck down into the tunnel
maintaining radio contact throughout as
they reported the direction they were
traveling and the distance it quickly
became apparent to Foundation Personnel
that this was no ordinary tunnel the
warehouse was positioned overlooking a
cliff and so the geography was not
physically possible as the street
sweepers descended further into the
tunnel they noted there was increased
levels of carbon monoxide radio contacts
started to dip in and out losing signal
as they went further downhill just at
the edge of their signal with the
foundation the trucks stopped and opened
its trailer door inside was just a
single piece of parchment with the words
I'm just delivering a message written on
it after the usual 60 seconds the
trailer door closed and the truck
continued after they had passed the
kilometer Mark the radio signal worsened
quickly and after a couple of scrambled
messages the team down there were not
heard from again the channel stayed open
for another six hours before the
foundation made the decision to announce
the agents missing in action in March
2015 over three years later a radio
signal came into contact with the
foundation again from Birmingham Alabama
it was from the headset of the squad
leader who had gone into the tunnel
initially confused as to who had gained
access to the cons channel the
foundation demanded that the agent State
his full name and rank the agent himself
confused obliged questioning why they
were so suspicious he and his team
claimed to have only lost contact for
about 15 minutes they had followed the
FCP a little further until carbon
monoxide levels had risen too high to
continue at which point they had watched
the truck disappearing into the distance
as they walked back to the surface all
agents have undergone extensive
psychological Rehabilitation to settle
them back into society as well as
classes to fill them in on things like
the London Olympics the Ice Bucket
Challenge and Gangnam Style as for
scp-2590 it is back out on the roads
roaming around Birmingham Alabama
continuously never stopping for fuel
always obeying the rules of the road
occasionally opening its trailer doors
to reveal new and bizarre findings now
check out living ice cream van
scp-1386 and scp-342 a ticket to ride
for more